an iconic seaside town
millions of holidaymakers flock to
blackpool every year
to enjoy one of the country's most loved
coastlines
but just a few streets away from the
golden mile
there is real desperation
all right welcome you okay
how are we doing
sun is shining
are we all getting on
the amazing graze soup kitchen used to
feed around 40 people a night
but now up to 200 turn up every tuesday
and friday evening
for many it will be the only hot meal
they'll eat this week
people like james are having to make
grim
choices heat
or eat
i've never struggled like i have like i
have done it back in the last year
i've never had to struggle like that
i've always had enough to get me by
wonder if we are
wondering where the next couple coats
going to come from
two slices of bread half a dinner beans
or spaghetti hoops
at nighttime full of porridge for my
breakfast nothing during the day nothing
through the day he turned his gas off on
the 2nd of april and he doesn't know if
he can afford to switch it back on this
winter
he's already lost
a stone in weight it was updated four
pence for three hours instead of 42 so
then heating went off
that just stuck an extra jumper on the
evenings when it was still feeling
really really cool so you might have to
go through the whole winter
without your gas centralizing you're
prepared to do that because that's the
only choice you have yes i'm prepared to
do that just be just because of the cost
of having heating on for
a short three hours
let's see i'm so i've been thinking
about this last couple of months or so
i'm still sort of swiveling
the center also provides takeaway food
bags
stuff that is cheap to make
anything you can use the kettle
pot noodle cup of soups
snack pots
tea bags
and a drink
so we are giving
more and more of these
we have people coming that have got no
electricity they have accommodation but
no electricity
demand is growing but donations are
falling
both food
and money
so it's quite heartbreaking actually
this is usually
stacked to the ceiling uh
floor-to-ceiling with food and as you
can see we've got an empty store room
we've got literally
nothing left
the center was established to serve
blackpool's homeless and destitutes
but now they're seeing many more
low-income families the question they're
asking is
if it's going to get any worse what are
we going to do we can't cope now
and we're seeing more and more mental
health issues we're seeing more and more
issues around domestic violence in
families
we're hearing about
people's houses getting robbed for the
food in their cupboards women that would
have never broke their law in their
lives are going stealing food
you know we're we're seeing story after
story after story nightmare after
nightmare of the night when things are
getting worse and worse by the day
this growing anxiety will put even more
pressure on local mental health services
christina knows
she struggles with her mental health but
has been told she's on a long waiting
list and help
is months away you could be on the
waiting list for two years two and a
half years
before you even
get your name read on the register
that's what you were told yeah i've
waited two years to help with your
mental health yeah yeah i've not even
been seen for two years i've still been
waiting
christina is battling an addiction
to alcohol
and drugs
she tells me she would be dead
if it wasn't for this center
if i didn't have
um got the right help at the right time
i'd definitely been six foot under i
wouldn't have been here i wouldn't have
lasted another two weeks without the
help came to a better crisis point
before christmas and i've asked them
authorities for helping us to police
asked to crash this team rang them up
all hours of the night
and not one of them came out to see me
two days i was left in the flat um
then christmas day they started looking
for me thinking that you know i've
actually done something but two days
left me on my flat refusing to help me
and you've told them that yeah being
suicidal yeah i told them yeah that is
yeah
yeah soon christina will be too old to
use this center
it's more uncertainty
in her troubled young life
more people are dying in blackpool than
being born not surprising when you
consider it tops almost every league
table for poor health
cancer
heart disease
alcoholism drug abuse
teenage pregnancies
come on ladies and gentlemen bring your
kiddies
up when it applies every time you can
even add up your force to make it bigger
boys
this is a coastal community
with serious inner city problems
if you're a man living in blackpool you
can only expect to live till you're
about 54 before you start having serious
health issues that's lower than anywhere
else in england and it's about 10 years
less
than the national average and the
picture is almost as bleak for women
these problems are not new but the
pandemic has made things much worse for
the town's seasonal economy
blackpool's tourism sector lost 1
billion pounds in revenue
blackpool's broken
we need to fix it
that's not one organisation that's
everybody together
karen brown is a senior nurse who has
devoted her life to improving people's
health
she tells me blackpool suffers from
imported poverty
that's when people with problems come
here because of happier memories made on
childhood holidays for example
is it money
it's the skill and it's the desire and
it's the passion to get this right for
people and a lot of people have got that
but people burn out it's it's relentless
they're just battered at every housing
education mental health services i think
everybody's just battered at every point
but where do you even begin to fix
blackpool's problems we attract more
people with poor health serious health
conditions and you know so
and people who are healthy tend to leave
blackpool for other opportunities
elsewhere
many people including council leader
lynn williams think you start improving
lives
by improving housing
once busy bed and breakfasts are now
multi-occupancy bedsits and many are not
fit for purpose
it's a basic right for people to live in
decent quality accommodation and to
create that healthier better well-being
building more resilience to people and
you know it just creates happier
healthier areas in community and that's
what we want for blackpool
that belief is shared by the town's
health workers
there's an age discrepancy of about 10
years 65 years life expectancy over
there in males and close to 80 over
there in stanley so there's quite a big
difference
dr abeda muhammad is a local gp her
patients have more worrying problems
than their health how do we look at
accessing secondary and tertiary care
when we worried about our housing when
housing is not decent when
we don't have food on the table or
schooling and not you know children are
not being given the social support for
schooling so we need to look at all
those factors and that in itself will
improve the access to health care
the government says it understands the
urgency of the crisis in places like
blackpool
but the people here
don't believe it
christina does not know how long she
will have to wait for the help she needs
with her mental health
james does not know if he can afford to
cook his meals or heat his home
and the queues of desperate hungry sick
people
will grow
even longer